はいみなさんこんにちははじめ社長です偶にはこういう撮り方も
いいかなぁと思いまして
今日はこういう感じでー
俺のステージプラン9イスに座ってたら
ケツの肉がなんか
ビロンビロンしそうなんで
タテタカコ年取ったら
お尻を読んでなりそうなんでなんかこうすんって今度から動画取ろうかなと思いまして
これを期に
まあいろいろな場所で撮ってみようと思います
影響
ゼロカロリーゼリー de ゼロほい
現在のおっ
かダメな up できないこの市金 up できない
水の善意で0違うところは何チョコ0がなんかばっかになってるんですよ
マンゴーをくり抜いた
これがまたちょっと
子さんと言うというか
食べてみたいと思いましたねぇ
ああいい匂いですよ
なんか変な帽子ませんよそのまま食べます今日
ちょっと甘えけどおいしい
やっぱ0さっキロカロリーいうだけあってこうなんか
スッとしますね
度だけにならないというかやっぱ方神道制度だけど電解質的な高パントリー分
そういう感じが
します
ねあとでここも
なんか
あんまりハニーを負荷を与えない程度の
これでカレーゼロはん
中高女子も大きなも喜ぶと思いますね
まぁ今回話したかったのがこのぜひがメインじゃなくて
いや皆さん最近ですねー
なんだっけ
8 no
ペットで最近ですね youtube をやってる方達が
好きな男って言う
荒野からというか魔物にこう次から次へと大変なことによっているシーンでて
youtube やってる方だけじゃないんですけど
あの皆さんも
そういう好きもとことがいう妖怪がいるらしいんで皆さん気をつけてくださいね
いつ来るかわかりませんから
じゃ
ああ
いやだ予感がする
ねええええ
いろんなのこんなスレ
ああああああああああああああ